imagina que tenemos un contenedor que
tiene un cierto tipo de molécula
misteriosa también imagina que somos
capaces de medir la composición en masa
de la molécula misteriosa de alguna
forma sabemos que esta molécula tiene
73% en masa de mercurio y 27 por ciento
en masa de cloro es decir lo restante es
un 27% en masa de cloro pausa el vídeo y
con base en esto ve si puedes obtener
una fórmula molecular empírica probable
para esta misteriosa molécula y te voy a
dar una pista la tabla periódica te será
útil
bien vamos a trabajar juntos y para
ayudarnos hay que hacer las cosas un
poco más tangibles supongamos que la
masa de la molécula misteriosa que está
en el contenedor es de 100 gramos
podemos suponer que es de 1000 gramos o
de 5 gramos o el número que quieran pero
vamos a suponer que son 100 gramos ya
que esta cantidad ayudará con las
cuentas porque el objetivo principal es
encontrar la razón entre el número de
moles que tenemos de mercurio y el
número de moles que tenemos de cloro ya
que esto nos dará la probable fórmula
molecular empírica ahora si tenemos 100
gramos entonces en esta situación
tenemos 73 gramos de mercurio y podemos
encontrar la cantidad de moles de
mercurio al observar la masa atómica
promedio del mercurio es por ello que
nos es útil la tabla periódica podemos
ver que un molde mercurio son 200 puntos
59 gramos en promedio así que podemos
multiplicar esto por 1 entre 259 moles
por gramo cuando multiplicamos esto los
gramos se cancelan y nos quedamos con un
cierto número de moles así que si
dividimos 73 entre 200 puntos 59
obtenemos 0.36 y nos quedaremos con 0.36
porque este es un pequeño juego de
estimación y trabajaremos con dos cifras
significativas porque hay dos siempre
significativas en la más original del
mercurio entonces esto es
aproximadamente 0.36 moles y podemos
hacer lo mismo para el cloro si tenemos
27 por ciento en masa del cloro de los
100 gramos que suponemos entonces
tenemos 27 gramos
y cuántos gramos por mol tenemos bueno
cada molde cloro en la tierra tiene 35
punto 45 gramos como masa atómica
promedio
así que aproximadamente cuántos moldes
tenemos los gramos se cancelan y esto
tiene sentido tenemos una fracción de
mol porque 27 gramos es menor que 35.45
entonces hacemos la división de 27 entre
35.45 y obtenemos aproximadamente 0.76
moles y recuerda
estamos hablando de moles esta es la
cantidad de moles que tenemos de cloro y
esta es la cantidad de moles que tenemos
de mercurio podemos pensarlo como el
número de átomos de mercurio o cloro que
tenemos los moles son sólo la cantidad
específica dada por el número de
avogadro entonces tenemos 0.76 moles por
el número de avogadro de átomos de cloro
ahora cuál es la relación bueno parece
que por cada átomo de mercurio tenemos
aproximadamente 2 átomos de cloro si
tomamos
por 0.36 obtenemos a 0.72 y esto es
aproximado no es exacto pero cuando
haces un cierto tipo de análisis
empírico no obtendrás resultados exactos
pero creo que es mejor suponer la
relación más simple que mejor se
aproxime por lo tanto si tenemos la
relación de dos átomos de cloro por cada
átomo de mercurio la fórmula empírica
probable es que por cada átomo de
mercurio tenemos dos átomos de cloro y
esta es nuestra fórmula empírica
probable el nombre de esta molécula es
cloruro de mercurio tof y no vamos a
profundizar el porqué se llama así pero
eso es de hecho lo que teníamos en el
contenedor